you've heard a lot about string theory
on this channel maybe you're sick of it
but i'm not i find it fascinating and it
really fits in with what i call the
assayer project that i'll be telling you
more about on this channel ways to
determine if new theories of everything
and grand unified theories are truly
valuable pieces of theoretical gold or
if they're just worthless don't
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
we've heard interviews with michio kaku
juan maldasena lenny suskin and many
others about the different claims and
the different ways to test the claims of
string theory so i thought it'd be
interesting to take an experimentalist
perspective on string theory and how we
might glean new insights into the
structure of reality
based on the claims made by proponents
of string theory to do that i think it's
going to be really critical for us to
explore string theory so that we're all
on a common footing why do we need
string theory why was it invented the
original motivation came from a desire
to reconcile these two most phenomenal
creations of the 20th century general
relativity and quantum accounting gr
describes the effect of gravity as the
resulting effect of the curvature of
space-time that warps and changes the
trajectories of massive particles or
massless particles like photons due to
the presence of mass so mass curve space
time and curve space time as wheeler
said tells matter how to move quantum
mechanics describes the behavior of
subatomic particles on a framework far
removed from our classical expertise and
so we can't use our intuition from say
the equations of maxwell or the
equations of isaac newton classical
mechanics nevertheless quantum mechanics
is our perhaps the most best tested
theory of the microscopic behavior of
particles forces and fields general
relativity is our best description of
gravity and we actually use it every
time we use a gps receiver it computes
gravitational general relativistic
distortions that would otherwise lead us
astray and i always like to thank that
because i don't need more people yelling
at me for getting off course in life but
the challenge of reconciling quantum
mechanics the very small with the very
large of classical mechanics and general
relativity which is a classical field
theory
is about bridging the seemingly
unbridgeable gap and string theory comes
in there as well the question is can you
make string theory emerge and also play
nice with quantum mechanics as a way of
formulating the origin of space and time
or space time itself we've talked about
loop quantum gravity as a possible
solution i'll put a link to that video
over here
and we did a deep dive there and we
examined some of the claims that have
been made against loop quantum gravity
that it fails to meet certain
experimental observations or even make
new predictions nevertheless we'll talk
more about loop chronic gravity another
time
so we understand gravity as the effect
of curve space time what curve space
time as i said matter so you have this
interplay this non-linear behavior
between gravity and the effects of
gravity of matter causing gravity and
then being affected by ground so what
can we glean about the quantum world
which describes the behavior
trajectories etc and the future
descriptions of subatomic particles via
what are called wave functions we can
see the importance of string theory when
we look at how the classical description
of space-time and quantum mechanical
processes break down when you have
so-called ultraviolet divergences these
are places where we're effectively
dividing by zero we have infinitesimally
short distances and we have macroscopic
charges forces and fields and at those
regions the behaviors obtain breakdowns
and so you'd like to have a nice smooth
manifold rather than dealing with
infinitesimal point particles and we'll
get to those manifolds in just a bit
what string theory fundamentally says is
that particles are just
multi-dimensional strings that vibrate
like different notes plucked on a guitar
string when you play the right note the
strings can interact in different
manifestations they can be quarks they
can be photons they can be gluons
electrons and all of the fundamental
particles in the standard model of
particle physics at small scales though
these extra dimensions are hidden and we
don't recognize them so we have to look
at them and see why don't we see these
extra dimensions these dimensions be on
the familiar north south east west and
up and down the three dimensions of
space plus our one-time dimension
so we actually may need many many more
we don't experience these space-time
dimensions but an analogy could be uh if
you consider a bug imagine a bug and
he's going to meet his friend for a
little bite to eat there happens to be a
cookie on the floor but if the bug only
knows the x y coordinates of where that
bug is on the two-dimensional floor
surface his friend may miss the fact
that the first bug is actually sitting
on top of the cookie in in other words
in the third dimension the
two-dimensional plane the floor is
essentially the projection of a
three-dimensional surface onto one lower
dimension it's not exactly compactifying
we'll get to that but it's just a way of
representing that you may need more than
just the familiar dimensions that we
operate in and that we are familiar with
to describe the physical phenomena that
are of interest in this quantum theory
of gravity there actually was a theory
that added to the dimensions of space
and time an extra dimension and this
took place over almost 100 years ago and
it's known as kaluza klein theory and
it's really the ancestor of string
theory in a certain sense it's known not
to be successful in what its original
intent was to do namely kaluza and klein
intended to have a description of
electromagnetism
as sort of the fifth dimension the
dimension added to the three space
dimensions and one time dimension and
some of those vestiges of that ancestor
still remain and the theory of string
theory is practiced today so
that model colusa klein theory was ruled
out by observations that we make today
but it still provided a useful paradigm
to assess the importance and perhaps the
power that one gets when one adds an
extra dimension how can we reconcile the
math of these extra dimensions and make
things work out in the dimensions that
we can test in the lab
oftentimes string theory gets criticized
for being difficult if not impossible to
test and that it merely retrodicts
rather than predicting or conjecturing
new phenomenon which is what you'd like
to do in a very very powerful theory
let's take a step back to the beginning
we're trying to combine general
relativity with quantum mechanics now
matter at small scales will also have
general relativistic effects the
question is do we mandatorily need a
quantum mechanical description of
gravity at the smallest scale we
certainly don't need it for planets we
don't need it for galaxies etc those are
more or less irrelevant we may need it
at the ultimate origin of time if time
began with a singularity and also
conjectures that eliminate the need for
quantum mechanical or singularity type
events namely the bouncing cosmological
models that we considered in this video
i did about anna aegis and paul
steinhardt's bouncing cosmological model
so we don't need them on the biggest
scales the question is how much can we
do with the small-scale information that
we have gravity is dependent on
space-time geometry and quantum
mechanics doesn't require necessarily
the emergence of gravity in order to
describe say the properties of the
hydrogen atom so it's a little bit
tricky we have to go to situations that
we can't easily access in the laboratory
nevertheless it's a fair question as an
experimentalist as an assayer to ask
could you have predicted new phenomena
such as the two experiments that we've
talked about recently on the into the
impossible podcast namely the g minus
two experiment about the anomalous
magnetic moment of the muon put a link
to that conversation that i had with
professor dan hooper and also with james
beacham who we discussed the large
hadron beauty experiment the results out
of geneva where we discussed the large
hadron colliders results back this
spring i'll put a link to that video
over here we have the conversation about
the implications of that on a so-called
fifth force and maybe whether or not
these two experiments
should have been predicted by string
theory there are some including michio
kaku in this conversation over here we
talked about the god equation his claim
that string theory provides a manifest
description of the theory of everything
he claimed that those actual
experimental results were contained in
some sense in string theory's equations
i remain somewhat dubious and i ask you
to watch this video and tell me if you
agree because the ultimate claim is that
we the experimental physicists would
have to come up with the vacuum state
out of an infinite number of potential
vacuum states for string theory we'll
talk about what that means the standard
model of quantum electrodynamics
typically relies on these stick diagrams
often known as binding diagrams actually
they were invented by richard feynman
the renowned physicist of the 20th
century what string theory attempts to
do is replace these stick-like features
with tubes or manifolds tracing out the
world manifold not just the world line
of particles as they interact so we can
read the left version and translate to
the right version as follows the left
version describes two particles coming
together interacting and a single
particle emerging
on the right you have two closed loops
which are the simplest closed string
that come together and merge and out
comes another string and the shape of
another circular manifold those two
different
objects interact on the left as points
at a single point and you could see how
you might get infinities arising the
point where they interact is of zero
dimension so if they have finite energy
and finite charge finite mass etc you
could have infinite amounts of force
whether it be electromagnetic or
gravitational if you just rely on the
inverse square law separation right
however you have no such infinities they
come together and they join they kind of
mush together and they never go through
a singularity or a point like
ultraviolet divergence so rather than
look at particles
stream theorists look at
multi-dimensional strings vibrating in
space
where these strings would have a
resonant frequency a particle arises in
the classical sense when looking at
space-time geometry as we have been
doing we look at what are known as
closed strings
when we look at something like a point
particle like a quark or an electron
or a photon we look at what are called
open strings these attach to structures
known as brains shown on the left so we
see if space time arises from string
theory and we know that gravity is
represented as a feature curve four
dimensional space space-time but if it
emerges we would expect to see things
like electromagnetism on an equal basis
so we can add to the three plus one
dimensions of space-time we can add a
fifth dimension so theodor
uh caluza much like what string
theorists do today is searching for a
unification for the laws governing
gravity and the laws governing
electromagnetism so the laws of
governing gravity will be the three plus
one dimensions of general relativity and
the electromagnetic dimension will be an
extra dimension and that he
attempts to tack on and what oscar klein
did to it he saw problems with kaluza's
original model where the fifth dimension
could be effectively stored and then he
added the kalooza's theory and actually
formed a new version of it
electromagnetic phenomena like gravity
would result from the geometry of space
time
so kaluza realized that a fifth
dimension could be where the
electromagnetic phenomena would be
needed or where they would reside but
where does this fifth dimension reside
that was the key insight that connects
to what string theorists do to this very
day he realized that if the dimension of
electromagnetism the fifth dimension
were supremely compactified into a
microscopic sufficiently small space
then you could get around the problem of
are not observing them and then you
could do all the operations all the
differential equations that are done in
general relativity effectively and out
would pop out a field theory for
electromagnetism you could do the exact
same treatment with certain differential
operators on a five-dimensional manifold
and you would get equations of maxwell
out but you needed to do what was called
compactification compactification is
still central to our understanding of
string theory and perhaps to some
reconciliation of the so-called grand
unification of electromagnetism with the
strong and weak nuclear forces the
fundamental element of string theory
that allows for compactification and
additional dimensions far beyond the
three plus one dimensions that we know
and love is called the calabi yao
manifold these beautiful mesmerizing
shapes would be thought to be located at
every point in three-dimensional space
operating at every moment in time and
you could add six or seven of these
extra dimensions within a compactified
manifold that you couldn't tell
because at our current scales we're
still simply too far away from them to
perceive these things these are at
really far below the size scale of the
electron which we can't even observe and
shouldn't think about as a little tiny
classical baseball anyway and what
allows it to incorporate gravity as well
as the fermionic forces of matter that
we are familiar with in the form of of
particles and forces and fields so to an
experimentalist the situation is
somewhat murky we have predictions in a
mathematical level that truly are
intriguing they represent a potential
hope for physicists to unify the forces
that operate on the very smallest scales
with those that operate on the very
largest scales and yet we fail to
perceive an actual prediction of the
model that would have otherwise not been
made in other words the observations at
the large hadron collider when we talked
about the lhcb experimental results in
spring of 2021 with james beechum and we
talked about the g minus 2 results those
were not necessarily forecasted
predicted they were more obtained when
we look in the context of string theory
by looking and what i would consider a
retrodiction those are less satisfying
an analogy i like to give is albert
einstein's theory of general relativity
at first he could only make
retrodictions to explain the at that
time known behavior of the anomalies of
mercury's orbit so he knew that
mercury's orbit precessed anomalously
and that was advancing and so-called
perihelion advance and that
perihelion advance was
impossible to reconcile with the laws of
universal gravitation of isaac newton
and yet it was a retrodiction it wasn't
predicted by einstein it was explained
by einstein and that was wonderful and
magnificent however what's even more
wonderful more delightful more delicious
is if you make a new prediction one that
wouldn't have been expected a priori and
in that case einstein had a bounty of
these and one of them was the bending of
starlight by massive objects like the
sun which is confirmed in the famous
1919 eddington eclipse expedition
another that wouldn't be confirmed for
many more years was strong gravitational
lensing the shapiro time delays and also
the existence of gravitational waves
detected by the ligo experiment first in
2015 from the orbit of massive objects
known as black holes or neutron stars
compact objects moving very close at
relativistic speeds and finally
coalescing together producing enormous
showers of gravitational wave energy
those are predictions of the theory of
relativity what predictions are there in
the string theory landscape what can we
predict that we would not have known
about and could be surprised about it
would be wonderful to explain existing
phenomena such as the sizes of forces
and fields and coupling constants and
particle masses etc that would be great
we already know them we've measured them
we'd like to have a theory maybe that
predicts them or retrodicts them rather
but it would be very cool if the string
theory formalism could predict
a new phenomenon that would fit in
beautifully in the framework of string
theory and for now we have to wait for
that there would be virtue in looking at
maybe low energy limits of string
theoretic predictions to see if there is
data that are lurking in existing
experiments or near-term experiments so
thank you for joining me in this sub
episode entitled string theory for
experimentalist as part of the assayer
project to understand and to test and
compare against existing data
with new models and see what comes off
the stone thank you so much for going
into the impossible with me
i'm brian keating chancellor
distinguished professor of physics and
co-director of the arthur c clarke
center for human imagination
thanking you for watching this episode
of into the impossible